C'est très simple,
Il va y avoir deux équipes
Il faut juste répondre à des questions de culture youtubienne,
pour trouver qui est le taulier quoi.
Donc j'espère que vous avez révisé un petit peu.
ON ARRÊTE !
Bonjour et bienvenue sur : Le quiz YouTube.
C'est du coup le grand quiz pour tester la culture YouTube des candidats qui sont autour de la table,
vous pouvez aussi jouer chez vous, c'est autorisé.
euuuuuh...
Il y a, quand même un très grand trophée à gagner,
qui est juste ici,
le trophée du grand gagnant du quiz YouTube.
A gauche c'est le diamond play button
Que je garde ! S'il vous plait hein
Je suis désolé……
A ma gauche nous avons Squeezie, bienvenue !
Bonjour, merci de m'avoir invité !
Nous avons le grand JD.
Bonjour merci !
Qui vient directement de Suisse,
Vous serez la team Jelly.
A ma droite nous avons Seb la frite.
Bonjour merci !
Non, merci d'être là !
Et Emma cakecup.
Exactement.
Emma  cake up ?
CakeCup, oui c'est très compliqué à dire je... Je te pardonne.
Vous serez la team Kitty,
Ça c'est Natoo.
Et, et Jelly c'est... ?
Et Jelly c'est le chien... Est-ce que quelqu'un le connait ?
Est-ce qu'on gagne un point si on donne la réponse ?
de heuuuuu... de enjoyphoenix.
voilà, ils gagnent déjà un point..
C'est faux !
alors on va commencer avec ce que l'on appelle le preroll, ça va être des petits QCM.
TEAM kitty  est ce que vous vous êtes prêts?
Attention première question :
Quel youtubeur n'existe pas ?
-Medouille fait l'andouille ;
-Maël fait le fifou ;
-Momo le déglingo ;
ou Timéo fait le zouave ?
Zouave, zouave c'est impossible !
Non mais zouave, mais si !
Alors, medouille fait l'andouille quand même ! Non mais medouille fait l'and.. Ouais je sais pas.
Il y a 3 comptes qui existent, il n' y a pas forcément des vidéos sur tout
Donc les comptes c'est pas toi qui les a créé ?
Bah non ! Moi j'ai rien créé du tout,
il y en a 1 seul qu'on a inventé.
Moi je partirais sur le zouave.
T'en es sûr ?.. Non vas y jee..
Comment veux tu que j'en sois sûr ?
Non mais là limite j'ai l'impression de jouer ma vie !
Euuuh, ouais vas y.
Timéo fait le zouave ?
Vas y.
C'est un point pour la TEAM kitty !
OH mon dieuuu ! BRAVOOO !
Non mais les applaudis pas !
Il nous faut un check !
On faiit.. ça !
Ouais !
Hum.. Vous êtes prêts Team Jelly ?
Alors, sur Youtube, vous ne trouverez pas le challenge suivant :
-Essaie de ne pas bander ;
-Essaie de ne pas lâcher un pouce bleu ;
-Essaie de ne pas chanter ;
-Essaie de ne pas faire caca.
Ça, je l'ai vu.
Tu l'as vu celui là ?
Je l'ai vu.
T'as vu les 3 ?!
Il me semble que ça, je l'ai vu ouais.
Attends, t'es passé de "je l'ai vu" à "il me semble".
Tu l'as vu ou il te semble ?
Donc je pense que c'est euuh..
Moi c'est ce que j'ai dit, et à mon avis c'est ça
Je.. euh.. Prend les responsabilités.
NOON ! Non Non Non, pas pour la première question !
Essaie de ne pas bander
On l'a déjà vu
Regarde les, ils sont d'accords.
Essaie de ne pas lâcher un pouce bleu j'ai déjà vu.. Non ! Je suis pas sûr, ça je suis pas sûr,
Et essaie de ne pas chanter, ça, j'ai déjà vu donc c'est, à mon avis..
Tu nous as fais un 50/50, c'est bien !
Ouais baaah..
A mon avis, c'est "essaie de ne pas faire caca".
Et quand on parle de caca, j'ai fais l'homme caca, j'ai fais plein de vidéos caca, ça me parle.
Et tu tapes régulièrement caca sur Youtube.
Bah oui !
Allez, vas y ! Essaie de ne pas faire caca.
C'est "essaie de ne pas lâcher un pouce bleu".
T'es deg' hein ?
Ça m'a brisé le cœur.
Je suis dégoûté.
Je suis pas bien aussi là !
Team Kitty, n'est ce pas ?
Quelle expérience sociale IBRATV n'a jamais faite ?
-Faire croire qu'il piège un pédophile ;
-Faire croire que les clowns tueurs existent ;
-Faire croire qu'il sauve un chien des flammes ;
-Faire croire qu'il sauve un racket.
Franchement ? Je crois que je sais.
Les clowns ?
Non, les clowns il l'a fait.
Moi je sais que "les pédophiles" il l'avait fait, j'ai vu la vidéo
Non pour moi, c'est le chien dans les flammes.
Non parce qu'il faut déjà qu'il y ait un incendie donc..
Non mais..
Woa ! T'es un génie frère !
C'est un truc de ouf.
Non mais je pense pas qu'il se soit chié à ce point.
"Quelle expérience sociale IBRATV n'a jamais faite ?"
Il n'a jamais fait croire qu'il sauve un chien des flammes, effectivement.
Bien joué, c'est un point pour vous.
Ah vous êtes verts !
Non mais c'est FACILE !!
Tout le monde ici avait la réponse ! C'est vrai ou pas ?
Team Jelly.
Laquelle de ces Story Time n'existe pas ?
Attend mais y'a un blèm là !
Doit y avoir un complot, y'a vraiment un complot !
-J'ai couché avec le copain de ma pote ;
-Ma pote a couché avec mon copain ;
-J'ai poignardé ma sœur ;
Ou ma sœur m'a poignardé.
Non mais !?
C'est les même !
C'est pareil mais inversées !
C'est tellement vicieux !
Mais grave !
On peut même pas ...
C'est hyper vicieux quoi !
Même si on procède par élimination, il en reste 2.
Qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on fasse ?
Il y en a 3 qui existent, hein je rappelle.
Bon, cette fois c'est quii..
Non non !
Non parce que je me suis planté tout à l'heure.
Et là j'en ai vraiment aucune idée, honnêtement..
Là je suis... Ouais, j'en ai AU-CUNE idée.
"J'ai couché avec le copain de ma pote"
Ça je pense que c'est possible.
Oui mais "ma pote a couché avec mon copain" ?
C'est ça le problème !
C'est impossible !
Non, je trouve que c'est plus beau "ma pote a couché avec mon copain" que "j'ai couché avec le copain de ma pote"
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas.
Dans mon cerveau ça sonne mieux.
Si tu regardes une vidéo "j'ai poignardé ma sœur", t'es un FDP.
Le pouce rouge il est là, les gens vont mettre le pouce rouge.
Ils vont faire : "Non mais t'es qui toi ?".
Alors que si c'est sa sœur qui l'a attaqué, ils vont faire : "Ah mon pauvre, qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?".
Donc je pense que c'est plus "ma sœur m'a poignardé".
Vas y !
Toi vas y !
Non non non ! Moi j'ai déjà dit avant.
J'étais sur le caca là, les sœurs, le poignard.. C'est plus toi.
C'est à moi ?
Alors "j'ai poignardé ma sœur".
Et c'est un point ! Enfin !
Là, il m'a donné la force.
J'avoue.
C'est facile, facile.
Pour l'instant.
On est arrivé à la fin du preroll.
Du coup..
On a perdu ?!
Non non ! Bah attendez, c'est la fin de la première manche.
Le gars il a un point : "gé un point keski se passe ?".
Non non.
On va enchaîner sur une épreuve de rapidité d'accord ?
Ça va parler essentiellement de youtuber francophone, ça s'appelle : "Quel youtuber ?".
Je dis l'intitulé, et il va falloir biper  en premier et me donner la réponse.
Quel youtuber était policier ?
NATOO !
Ouiiiii !
Et nous avons un point pour la Team Jelly.
J'ai même pas eu le temps d'avoir entendu la question mais..
Quel youtuber a sorti un film sur lui ?
Rémi Gaillard !
Ouiiiii !
Attention, ils commencent à stresser là.
Ouais ouais, là...
Quel youtuber a fait Secret Story ?
Euh, Guillaume Ruchon ?
Eh bin voilà, c'est un point pour la Team Kitty ahah
Bravo bravo, je suis nulle !
Quel youtuber a fait une vidéo sur son contrôle fiscal ?
C'est une blague ?
Mec, faut oser quand même
Ouais grave !
Poisson fécond ?
Non.
Nooooon !
David Lafarge pokémon !
Mais appuies !
Un dernier attention !
Personne ! ;)
Non. *pfffffff*
C'est mignon, c'est très mignon.
Eh bien c'était Siphano !
Avec une vidéo qui s'appelle : "mon contrôle fiscal".
Ah okey, d'accord.
Attention, rapidité.
Quel youtuber a un diamond play button ?
Cyprien !
Ouiii !
Bien joué !
Pardon, on y retourne.
Hum, quel youtuber a fait une vidéo pour l'armée ?
Tibo In Shape !
Eh ils sont forts !
Non mais moi je suis totalement à l'ouest !
Non mais ils ont le buzzer plus près.
J'ai eu la miniature en suggestion pendant dix ans donc j'estime que...
Un dernier, attention, rapidité s'il vous plait.
Quel youtuber a plagié plusieurs vidéos américaines, même un plan de porte qui se ferme ?
Math Podcast !
Ouiii !
Bien joué !
Ça m’énerve ! J'avais toutes les réponses mais ça voulait pas..
Oui pareil !
Rhho ça va hein.
C'est une remontée fantastique !
Hein, de la Team Jelly.
Euh Kitty qu'est ce qui se passe là ?
Ouais, ouais, ça va pas.
Non mais je crois que Squeezie nous a dissuadé au début,
Il était là en mode : "ouais je crois que lui il est fort et tout"
Alors qu'en fait c'est lui qui est le plus fort.
Ouais, là j'étais à fond.
On va arriver à la dernière manche avant la finale.
C'est quoi les scores ?
6 à 3 pour vous..
Tu voulais juste re dire que t'étais le plus fort c'est ça ?
Non non ! C'est pas.. En plus c'est marqué donc..
Donc, maintenant, c'est un QCM basé sur des miniatures, ça s'appelle "Le Putaclic".
Donc pour cette manche, c'est 2 points gagnés pour chaqueuh...
Aaaaaaah
Aperçu putaclic trouvé.
Quel est le titre de cette vidéo ?
Du coup, c'est une vidéo qui existe vraiment.
Ok.
-StoryTime : Amoureux en temps de guerre ;
-Comment on s'est rencontré ;
-Le jour où tout a basculé ;
-On intègre les forces spéciales.
Bonne chance.
Franchement bonne chance.
C'est dur !
"Comment on s'est rencontré" non ? Ils s'embrassent je me dis.
Nooon, c'est trop..
Non mais alors ? La miniature c'est pas trop peut être ?
Non mais genre, toi tu te fous qu'il y ait des flingues ?
Mais je me dis, ils se sont peut être rencontré euuh..
Non mais je sais même pas comment débattre et dire lequel est le mieux parce que dans tous les cas..
Non mais aussi, on intègre les forces spéciales, je pense vraiment pas
C'est super chaud !
Déjà on peut enlever "le jour où tout a basculé"
Et si c'est ça, vraiment, ça se fait pas.
Moi je dirais "comment on s'est rencontré"
Je sais pas..
Une histoire un peu folle.
Ouais, une histoire un peu dingue.
Et c'est 2 points pour la Team Kitty.
Ouais, on aurait dit pareil.
Team, n'est ce pas, Jelly.
Alors :
Quel est le titre de cet aperçu ?
-Dégustation à l'aveugle qui tourne mal ;
-Touche mon corps challenge ;
-Vous ne devinerez jamais se que j'ai touché ;
-Je ne contrôle plus ma main.
Il est suisse le type hein, il faut quand même le préciser.
Tu connais ??
Ouais.. C'est mon frère.
Non, euh.. mais après j'ai jamais vu cette vidéo donc voilà.
Moi je sais, y'a une mode aux US c'est euh.. Tu dois faire deviner une partie de ton corps à l'autre..
Oui oui bah oui, on est là dessus.
On a envie de dire "touche mon corps challenge"
Maiiiis...
"Dégustation à l'aveugle qui tourne mal" je comprends pas comment il a pu...
Passer d'un mec qui mange un bonbon à un gars qui touche un sein, je sais pas comment il a fait.
Donc je pense que c'est faux.
"Vous ne devinerez jamais ce que j'ai touché" c'est quand même un peu drôle
donc je pense pas qu'il ait eu assez d'inspi pour faire ça
Et "je ne contrôle plus ma main"
Franchement, c'est touche mon corps challenge.  Moi je pense que c'est ça
parce que c'est typiquement le genre à faire simple, tu vois ?
En plus y a le combo le rond rouge affiché et le moins de 18 : touche mon corps challenge
C'est - tu vois ? Ouais, touche mon corps challenge !
Le créateur... Putaclic : allez, c'est parti !
On est d'accord ?
On est d'accord.
Et c'est 2 points pour l'équipe Jelly
C'est facile, c'est facile...
Hein, faut... Il faut rester, euh... Ok ?
On reste dans le game :
Attention ! Sur cet aperçu-là, sur cette miniature :
"Il me trompe, je me venge : ça tourne mal"
Oh mon dieu, mais what ?
"Ma copine a perdu sa moon cup (choquant)"
"Je me suicide pour la faire rager"
"Petite amie morte challenge prank (extreme)"
Non mais c'est une blague : "petite amie morte"
Attends, déja, ça, si c'est vraiment elle, genre si c'est "je me venge" et qu'elle est morte...
Elle met pas ça sur Youtube
On peut l'éliminer !
Moi je pense que c'est "je me suicide pour le faire rager"
Non, je suis pas d'accord.
T'es pas d'accord ?
Non
Euh, là on n'est pas d'accord. On est pas d'accord !
"Ma copine a perdu sa moon cup" : ça vous - ça vous...
Ah non mais ça, je trouve ça génial !
Moi, c'est le seul titre où j'aurai cliqué
J'ai envie de te faire confiance mais si c'est pas ça, je serai très déçu !
*rires* La menace ! Attention !
(Emma CakeCup) Ouais , bah je sais pas là , j'ai  un énorme doute . Tu me fous le doute . Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
(SEB)  Pierre , feuille , ciseaux .
(Cyprien)  Pierre , feuille , ciseaux .Et voilà ça dégage .
(SEB)  ''Petite amie morte''
(Cyprien ) Donc petite amie morte challenge  prank (extreme)
(Cyprien) et c'est...2 points !
(Cyprien) Vous pouvez gagner encore 2 points
(Cyprien ) Attention...sur cette aperçu là c'est je montre ma **** à des inconnus
(Cyprien ) Faire caca dans la rue Challenge .
(Cyprien ) Bagarre à cause d'un Free Hugs
(Cyprien) Ou draguer des meufs en couple tourne mal.
(JD) Moi je reviens sur le caca
(Squeezie ) Mais nan mais il serait pas allé l'embrouiller
(Squeezie ) Il l'aurait esquivé  , il aurait fait
(Squeezie) mais qu'est ce qu'il fait ce mec ?
(JD) T'as raison .
(Cyprien ) donc c'est ?
(Squeezie ) Je montre ma kékette à des inconnus
(Cyprien)  Pas du tout . C'est : draguer des meufs en couples (tourne mal)
(Squeezie ) Mec , comment ça peut tourner mal au point qu'il se retrouve à poil ?
(Cyprien) Mec .
(Cyprien) Je l'ai déjà dit , on ne juge pas ici .
(Squeezie ) Pardon *rires*
(Cyprien) Effectivement il s'est retrouvé à poil , il s'est dit :
(Cyprien) Draguer des meufs en couples ( tourne mal ) c'est le titre adéquate à cette vidéo .
(Cyprien) Nous avons des grands gagnants ici . C'est la team Jelly .
(Cyprien) Qu'on peut applaudir ! BRAVO!
(Cyprien) Déçu ? Pas trop déçu ?
(Emma) Un peu , Un peu .
(SEB) J'suis fair-play ça va que je vous aime bien
(Cyprien) ah oui désolé . ça vous as plu ?
(Seb )  ( Emma)   Ouais , c'était col
(Emma) Je...me suis rendue compte que j'étais très nulle , vraiment .
(Cyprien) Franchement , ils ont commencé super bien
(SEB) Moi aussi , je me suis rendu compte...qu'elle était très  nulle .
(Cyprien ) J'propose que les deux gagnants m'entourent .
(Cyprien) Vous allez changez un petit peu de place s'il vous plaît . Pour la dernière manche !
(Squeezie) T'es resté du côté gagnant
(JD ) J'ai fait exprès à part ça , j'ai fait exprès !
(Cyprien) Alors qui, va gagner , ce fameux trophée du Quiz Youtube
(Squeezie) IL EST si beau !
(Cyprien) Il va falloir répondre un maximum de bonnes questions en une minute .
(Cyprien) Qui veut commencer ?
(Squeezie)  ouais vas-y .
(JD) Alors , je commence !
(Cyprien) Tu commences ?
(Squeezie) Il a le droit de passer ? Juste il a le droit de dire '' je passe ''
(Cyprien) Bien sûr tu peux passer .
(Cyprien) Et il faut répondre à la question ou terminer la phrase
(Jd) D'accord
(Cyprien)  Très bien. TOP ! Quel est le premier film avec Norman ?
(Jd) Paranormales Activitées
(Cyprien) Quel collectif a écrit et réalisé : Les dissociés ?
(Jd) Putain... Je suis stressé je passe ! Je l'avais mais...
(Cyprien) Y'a combien de What the cut en tout ?
(Jd) Heuuu je passe
(Cyprien) Prenez le temps...
(Jd) ... de regarder mes vidéos je passe
(Cyprien) Vrai ou faux : sur les 100 plus gros youtubers de France 13% sont des femmes
(Jd) Faux !
(Cyprien) C'est vrai.
(Cyprien) Un youtuber qui vient de Grenoble ? (Jd) Mister V évidemment !
(Cyprien) En quelle année à été créé Youtube ?
(Jd) Heu... en France ou heu 2000 2000...
2000 2000 nan mais je veux dire
en france ou... 2005 !
(Cyprien) Oui ! (Jd) 2004 !
(Jd) 2005 !  (Cyprien) 2005. Combien d'abonnés pour recevoir
le ruby play button ? (Jd) Ha oui oui 10 millions
(Cyprien) 50 millions..
(Cyprien) Quel jeu flash a été rendu culte par PewDiePie ?
(JD) Je passe.
(Cyprien) D'où vient Kamini ?
(JD) Euuuh...de Marly-Gomont !
(Cyprien) Une vidéo où on déballe les vêtements qu'on a acheté ça s’appelle...?
(JD) Hum euuuuh...une morning routine ?
J'EN SAIS RIEN, J'EN SAIS RIEN
J'étais trop stressé !
(Cyprien) On peut l'applaudir, quand même !
(JD) C'est hyper stressant en fait
(Squeezie) Oh naaan JD !
(Emma CakeCup) C'est bien, c'est bien, c'est bien !
(Cyprien) Le premier film avec Norman ?
(Squeezie) Pas très normales activités
(Cyprien) Qui a réalisé les Dissociés ?
(JD) Suricate.. Mais je l'avais, je l'avais !
(Cyprien) Combien de What the cut ?